over the past 60 years Oscar winner Jeff
Bridges has gone from child actor to
leading heartthrob to laid-back
counterculture icon but he's also a bit
of a Renaissance man
adding painting music and photography to
his artistic repertoire his photography
is the subject of a new book it features
behind the scene images from some of his
most memorable films Anthony Mason
recently spent some time with bridges in
Los Angeles both in front of the lens
and behind it
sure 28 now major panning lands Jeff
Bridges has always been passionate about
taking pictures where did your love of
photography come from
I guess borrowing would be the kind of a
word rather than stealing my father's
Nikon setting up a little darkroom in my
bathroom you know putting the tinfoil on
the windows and being in there with that
red light with my tunes going on the
whole concept of time goes out the
window just the idea of capturing time
like that but when he started acting he
left the darkroom behind until 1976 when
he starred in King Kong my character
Jack Prescott had a camera I said well
I'm going to load that thing and take
pictures you know that started a
tradition of taking pictures on his film
sets photographs from King Kong The
Fabulous Baker boys and the Big Lebowski
were included in a first volume of his
pictures now Bridges has released
pictures volume two including photos
from the sets of True Grit crazy heart
and Seabiscuit in which he starred with
Tobey Maguire and Elizabeth Banks what
happened here I gave her a bloody nose
I said oh I'm sorry I'm sorry can I take
your picture he also turned his camera
on the inflatable crowd in the racing
scene gosh you got all those extras up
there and you're all dressed and some
amazing then I got closer and I saw it
was these guys Bridges who we met at the
Annenberg space for photography in Los
Angeles says the tool of his trade now
is a 35 millimeter wide lux panning
camera which allows him to shoot the
dual image comedy tragedy shots of his
acting friends he gave me a
demonstration Bridges was encouraged to
go into acting by his father Lloyd
Bridges who starred in the 50s and 60s
TV show Sea Hawks in which young Jeff
made several appearances you were on the
fence at one point though oh yeah I sure
was for quite a while I had maybe 10
movies under my belt yeah before I said
you know what this is for me I'm not a
product of nepotism I don't think I
would have got into the movies without
my dad saying come on come on you know
but you have to be good to stay in the
moon well that's also true but in the
beginning I said I don't want to get get
the part just because who my dad is
that changed Bridges says after he
initially passed on a part in the 1973
film The Iceman Cometh and a director he
just worked with called him you've
turned down John Frankenheimer
Iceman Cometh oh yeah I'm I'm bushed
Marty you know I just pushed you're an
ass hung up on me but you think I made
up a phony don't you bridges took the
part and eventually found ways to
include his love of music and for
tog Rafi in his acting career but his
favorite photograph is not his own oh
yeah my prized possession you're talking
about yeah in his wallet he keeps a
snapshot of the moment he and his wife
Susan met in 1975 and so I have a
photograph of the first words that my
wife and I shared me asking her around
her saying no and here's that moment you
know look at that isn't that while he
was smitten he says by her beauty and
her pair of black eyes from a recent car
accident here's a close-up of her and
her black something susan appears in the
book visiting the set of True Grit
so does Bridges stand in who he's been
working with even longer there's my old
buddy Lloyd Catlett you know we've done
nearly 70 films together we met on the
last picture show how unusual is it to
have a stand-in through your whole
career completely in you you I think
we've got a whole the record I would I
would think what satisfaction you get
out of taking pictures opening that that
proof sheet and seeing what you took you
know I just love that surprise you
always have high expectations when
you're making a movie yeah you know and
every once in a while it exceeds those
expectations in deal oh yeah man and
that happens in the photographs too
every once in a while you've gotten out
of the way appropriately and the thing
is just captured you know and feels
great bridges did not even know that the
photo of him meeting his future wife
Susan existed until about a decade after
he married her in 1977 the makeup artist
who took the picture on a film set in
Montana found it in some old files and
mailed it to bridges out of the blue the
actor says he keeps it with him
everywhere he goes that's like the laws
of attraction photography and then he
gets the picture and he kept on it
but guys is there any film that Jeff
Bridges is in that you haven't just like
loved absolutely well that one I didn't
even know about that first book yes I
love seeing this now is photography and
like he's just so beautifully expressive
in these pictures I love when Anthony
can do stories like this where he
actually takes us into the life of
somebody who you think you know because
you've seen him on the screen for so
many years but you've discover something
completely different about this did you
notice that little bit of a dude came
out yes does a by the dude abides to do
to by
you